mes chers collègues j'ai la joie de vous
retrouver ce soir pour l'audition de
Monsieur Bernard Cazeneuve que je
remercie d'avoir accepté de se présenter
devant notre commission d'enquête
monsieur le Premier ministre comme vous
le savez nous enquêtons sur les
violences qui ont émaillé et
manifestations dans notre pays au cours
du printemps dernier c'est
rassemblements présenté deux dimensions
il y a eu d'une part la contestation de
la réforme des retraites qui a donné
lieu à des exactions essentiellement
urbaines et il y a eu d'autres par
l'opposition à des projets
d'infrastructures dans des espaces
principalement ruraux dont sainte Soline
est devenu l'exemple votre expérience
nous sera particulièrement précieuse
pour remettre ses événements en
perspective puisque dans les fonctions
éminentes que vous avez exercées place
Beauvau d'une part et à l'hôtel de
Matignon d'autre part vous avez été
confronté à des épisodes similaires en
effet chacun se souvient des
affrontements qui s'étaient produits à
propos du barrage de en 2014 puis de la
loi travail en 2016 avec les
conséquences dramatiques que l'on sait
un questionnaire vous a été
préalablement préalablement transmis par
notre rapporteur Florent Boudier qui
nous rejoint dans quelques minutes mais
je préfère quand même commencer à
l'heure je vous invite si cela vous est
possible à communiquer vos réponses
écrites sur les sujets qui n'auront pas
été abordés au cours de l'audition et
qui ont été mentionnés dans le
questionnaire de monsieur le rapporteur
alors comme le l'usage il me revient
généralement d'introduire nos échanges
avant de vous donner la parole puis de
donner aussi la parole aux membres de la
commission d'enquête qui souhaiterait la
prendre en premier lieu comment
expliquer cette éruption de violence qui
devient désormais habituel à l'occasion
des manifestations ce qui semble
finalement assez récent sur le long
terme faut-il y voir une réaction à la
crise de la démocratie représentative ou
est-ce le symptôme d'une incapacité
croissante de certaines mouvances elle
se plier à la décision légale et
majoritaire qui caractérise l'état de
droit et en second lieu les forces de
sécurité intérieure bénéficient des
nouveaux instruments que leur procure le
progrès technique pour exercer
évidemment leur mission je pense au
drone aux produits marquants voire au
quad qui ont été déployés à Sainte
Soline comme nous avons pu le voir
lorsque nous sommes allés sur place il y
a quelques semaines ces équipements
permettent-ils de compenser le retrait
progressif de l'arsenal des armes
intermédiaires qui facilitait le
maintien à distance puisqu'on voit que
c'est aussi l'une des difficultés et
donc comment concilier au que leur usage
avec les exigences de l'État de droit et
la protection des libertés fondamentales
un monsieur le Premier ministre avant de
vous donner la parole et en application
de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance numéro
58-1100 du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires je vais vous demander de
prêter serment comme le veut l'usage de
dire la vérité toute la vérité rien que
la vérité c'est pourquoi je vous invite
à activer votre micro et de lever votre
moins main droite et de dire je le jure
je le jure
je vous remercie monsieur Premier
ministre et sans tarder je comme je l'ai
indiqué je vais vous passer la parole je
donnerai tout à l'heure aussi évidemment
la parole à Monsieur le rapporteur et
puis comme je l'indiquais aux autres
collègues qui souhaiteraient la prendre
mais je vous en prie Monsieur le Premier
Ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président et merci mesdames et messieurs
les députés de m'offrir l'hospitalité de
cette salle de la de votre commission
pour me permettre de livrer mon
témoignage je voudrais avant de livrer
d'ailleurs apporter quelques précisions
sur le contexte dans lequel vous
m'amenez à m'exprimer devant vous
d'abord j'ai compris que ce que l'on
attendait c'est que je fasse part de
l'expérience qui a été la mienne au
regard des événements qui viennent de se
produire c'est un exercice assez
difficile surtout après qu'on a prêté
serment de dire la vérité pour des
raisons qui tiennent au fait que la
plupart des événements dont vous faites
référence sont quand même désormais
assez anciens
que vous savez que les ministres sont
contraints de déposer la totalité de
leurs archives après qu'ils ont cessé
d'exercer leur responsabilité
ministérielle qui n'est pas très sain
lorsqu'on a été ministre de l'Intérieur
de continuer à entretenir des relations
avec ses collaborateurs y compris
lorsqu'on est soumis à la question de
votre commission pour essayer de
reconstituer les faits auxquels on a pu
participer il arrive que certains le
fassent mais je ne le fais pas et par
conséquent le témoignage que je vais
vous livrer il est le résultat de la
convocation de mes souvenirs et 8-9 ans
après il peut y avoir dans ses souvenirs
des choses qui n'ont pas le degré de
précision qu'une commission comme la
vôtre est en droit d'attendre et je vous
remercie de bien vouloir par avance m'en
excuser deuxième élément vous m'invitez
à commenter dans le questionnaire qui
m'a été adressé toute une série de
décisions qui ont été prises depuis
alors c'est une difficulté inversée
symétrique à celle que je viens
d'évoquer parce que je n'ai pas la
totalité des éléments même aucun élément
entre les mains n'étant plus au
gouvernement n'ayant pu accès aux
services du ministère de l'intérieur ni
au service du renseignements ni au
service de sécurité police et
gendarmerie pour me permettre d'évaluer
autrement qu'à travers la lecture de la
presse et quelques commentaires qui
parfois sur ces sujets sont
approximatifs orientés c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire ce qu'est la réalité
de la situation à laquelle les forces de
l'ordre ont pu être confrontées sur le
théâtre des opérations auxquelles elles
ont pu faire face à des difficultés qui
ont pu contribuer à leur mise en cause
par conséquent par souci de rigueur
ce que je me propose si vous en êtes
d'accord c'est
d'expliquer ce que j'ai fait les
circonstances dans lesquelles j'étais
amené le faire les contraintes
auxquelles j'ai été confrontées en le
faisant
ce témoignage d'ailleurs pourra
éventuellement éclairer quelques-unes
des difficultés actuelles et bien
entendu si vous posez des questions
concernant le contexte auquel vous êtes
confronté qui justifie la création de la
commission d'enquête je vous donnerai
mon sentiment mais
en pondérant ce sentiment de tout ce que
je n'ai pas comme information et qui
pourrait venir parce que c'est un
exercice quand même qui appelle autre
chose que des approximations contredire
y compris au terme de vos travaux ce que
j'aurais pu avancer devant vous le
premier point sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est sur l'extrême difficulté
à laquelle nous avons été confrontés
dans le cas des opérations de maintien
de l'ordre quel que soit d'ailleurs leur
nature entre 2014 et
2017 qui est l'époque où j'étais mise de
l'Intérieur d'où venait ses difficultés
elles sont assez peu évoquées et je
voudrais le faire parce que elles
éclairent une grande partie des
problèmes qui furent les nôtres à ce
moment-là premier problème
un choix avait été fait je ne commande
pas son son contenu ni sa pertinence de
mettre en place la révision générale des
politiques publiques
la révision générale des politiques
publiques a conduit à la suppression de
13000 emplois dans la police et la
gendarmerie
pour ce qui concerne les forces en
charge du maintien de l'ordre
c'est-à-dire les forces spécialisées que
sont les escadons de gendarmerie mobiles
et compagnies républicaines de sécurité
ça s'est traduit par la disparition de
15 unités de force mobile
vous savez qu'il y a 160 à peu près
unités de force mobile un peu plus de
sens en neuf aujourd'hui pour la
gendarmerie une soixantaine pour la
police
que ces unités de force mobile ont des
effectifs différents selon qu'on est
dans la police ou la gendarmerie mais 15
unités de force mobiles en moins pour
assurer le maintien de l'or dans des
opérations dans des opérations notamment
des manifestations au sein desquelles se
trouvaient des groupes organisés et
violents étaient pour le ministère de
l'Intérieur une contrainte très
significative
deuxième élément et comme les 9000
emplois qui ont été créés sous le
quinquennat de François Hollande l'ont
été à mesure que le quinquennat se
déroulé et l'ont été à hauteur des
effectifs de 9000 à la fin du
quinquennat nous n'avons plus disposer
du rétablissement d'une partie des
moyens dont disposer les unités
spécialisées qu'à la fin de la période
deuxième élément
des unités de force mobile que nous
mobilisions pour les opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
était aussi utilisé à d'autres objectifs
pour des raisons qui tenaient au
contexte nous avons été confrontés à une
crise migratoire nous avons été
confrontés à une crise théorie
pendant ce christorie s'il y a eu des
tensions dans un certain nombre de
quartiers et nous avons été dans
l'obligation d'utiliser les unités
spécialisées dans le maintien de l'ordre
au contrôle des frontières
notamment au moment de la crise
terroriste pour des raisons qui te dit
au fait que fontex n'avait pas encore
été mis en place et que la réforme du
système d'information Schengen n'était
pas encore entrée en vigueur et qu'il
fallait par conséquent assurer un
minimum de contrôle destiné à éviter que
des individus qui étaient partis sur le
théâtre des opérations terroristes ne
reviennent sur le territoire national
pour frapper
et nous avons été soumis un très grand
nombre de demandes de maire de toute
sensibilité de présence d'unités de
force mobiles dans les quartiers quand
des tensions
survenaient qui pouvait aboutir à des
violences urbaines
donc nous avions non seulement une
contrainte sur les effectifs pour des
raisons qui tenaient aller RGPP et qui
pesait lourd mais nous avions également
à ce moment-là l'obligation d'utiliser
les unités de force mobile à d'autres
objectifs que le maintien de l'ordre ce
qui est compliqué considérablement
la réalisation des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre parce que bien
entendu lorsqu'il y avait des
manifestations en nombre et jamais
le droit de manifester n'a été remis en
cause
non c'est vrai
du peu de choses fausses mais on en
parlera pas vous voulez
il y a eu une manifestation qui a été
interdite à soi et j'ai reçu moi-même
les représentants des organisations
syndicales à Beauvau à la manifestation
était autorisé l'après-midi voilà donc
il n'y a pas une manifestation interdite
et c'est dans mon bureau que c'est
dénoué je dis ça pour votre information
parce qu'il m'arrive notamment
d'entendre par le truchement de votre
groupe parlementaire dans des
approximations à ce point grossière que
je suis absolument enchanté de pouvoir
profiter de cette commission pour
établir sur un certain nombre de points
l'incontestable vérité
si en plus de ça ça vous fait plaisir
j'en suis vraiment forte
troisième élément sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est sur le fait que les
moyens
alloués aux forces de sécurité
intérieures et notamment aux forces
spécialisées ont vu leur budget diminuer
pendant la période
2007-2012 de 20%
20%. et par conséquent 20% de diminution
du budget alloué aux forces de sécurité
intérieure dans le cadre de la révision
générale des politiques publiques ça a
des conséquences très importantes sur le
niveau d'équipement des forces et la
capacité des forces à faire face aux
missions qui leur incombent donc je dis
tout cela pourquoi parce que
lorsque des difficultés sont survenues
dans le cadre d'opérations difficiles
toutes ces contraintes ont très
lourdement pesées sur la capacité de
déployer de façon aussi souple que nous
l'aurions que nous souhaitons à l'époque
les forces de manière à leur permettre
de remplir leurs missions dans des
conditions de grande efficacité enfin il
y a un dernier point c'est l'importance
de la crise terroriste la crise
terroriste crée dans le pays une tension
extrême avec un risque
d'attentat de grande ampleur en
permanence et d'ailleurs il y a eu
pendant toute cette période
des attentats en nombre Charlie Hebdo le
Bataclan l'hyper cacher
l'attentat de Nice et d'autres encore et
nous avons dû pendant toute cette
période mobiliser énormément de moyens
dans des conditions contraintes alors
même que nous disposions d'une loi sur
le renseignement qui datait 1991 c'est à
dire d'une époque où il y avait ni
téléphone portable ni internet alors
même que ceux qui menacent ne nous
frapper disposaient alors de moyens
technologiques extrêmement
performant et communiquer entre eux par
des moyens cryptés moyens cryptés
engendrant des communications difficiles
à pénétrer avec des services
d'enseignement qui ne disposaient pas
des moyens technologiques alors pour
pouvoir entrer dans ces conversations
depuis les choses ont beaucoup changé
grâce à la loi de 2015 je crois que vous
avez évalué et il y a désormais une
possibilité pour les services de
renseignement de prévenir un certain
nombre de risques de risque de troubles
à l'ordre public il s'agisse du
terrorisme ou d'autres types de risques
le service de renseignement intérieur a
été reconstitué on ne peut pas éviter
des troupes graves alors publiques dans
le cadre de manifestations dans
lesquelles des groupes violents sont
susceptibles de
d'intervenir si on n'a pas un
renseignement intérieur qui est capable
d'évaluer les risques que présente ces
groupes avant que les manifestations se
tiennent je veux rappeler que la fusion
des renseignements généraux et de la DST
avait prévu une grande partie du
renseignement territorial de ces
capteurs et qu'il a fallu la création du
service central du renseignement
territorial redoter en Moyen-Âge humain
et en moyenne technique pour permettre à
ce service de pouvoir anticiper un
certain nombre d'événements qui jusqu'à
l'or ne pouvait pas l'être faute des
moyens que je viens de d'évoquer donc
c'est dans ce contexte que les
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
s'effectuer et je crois qu'il est
intéressant de le rappeler parce que
ces sujets sont rarement évoqués ils ont
été tout à fait déterminants il y a un
autre élément qui a beaucoup pesé c'est
la suppression de la formation la
direction centrale de la formation de la
police en 2008
et la suppression d'un certain nombre
d'écoles de formation de police de la
gendarmerie pendant la même période
or les opérations de maintien de l'ordre
même si les effectifs sont reconstitués
ne peuvent se faire dans d'excellentes
conditions que dès lors qu'il y a un
haut niveau de formation de ceux qui
interviennent sur le théâtre des
manifestations lorsque des troubles à
l'ordre public se produisent et la
recréation d'une direction
d'administration centrale en 2015-2016
la recréation d'écoles de la gendarmerie
et de la police par de la Saint-Astier à
Dijon et dans d'autres secteurs a permis
la mise en place d'un code de
déontologie en 2014 précisant très
de façon très cursive ce que sont les
responsabilités des forces de l'ordre
lorsqu'elles interviennent sur des
opérations maintien de l'ordre sont
autant d'éléments également qui sont
rarement rappelés qui me paraissent
absolument déterminants pour bien
comprendre ce que fut la période à
laquelle nous avons été confrontés
voilà le contexte deuxièmement sur
l'émergence des groupes violents poser
la question de savoir si ces groupes
constituent un phénomène nouveau si les
manifestations violentes sont un
phénomène nouveau si on a toujours eu et
quelle analyse on peut faire de
l'intrusion de ces groupes violents dans
les manifestations qu'il perturbe
jusqu'à mettre en difficulté en danger
les organisateurs de ces manifestations
eux-mêmes et parfois en danger des
représentants des forces de l'ordre
d'abord les manifestations violentes
ayant des toujours eu dans notre pays et
si vous relisez les débats qui ont lieu
au moment de
des manifestations 34 et des débats qui
ont eu notamment 1935 lorsque des
dispositions ont été prises si je me
souviens bien de nature réglementaire
destinée à définir les modalités
d'intervention des forces de sécurité
intérieure à ce moment là
les débats sur la
l'immersion
de l'émergence de cours violents dans
les manifestations étaient extrêmement
présent et les débats correspondaient à
peu de choses près aux interrogations
que vous soulevez au sein du Parlement
ou de votre commission d'enquête mais il
y a incontestablement un phénomène
nouveau ce phénomène nouveau il résulte
de la cristallisation au plan
international et notamment européen de
groupes extrémistes
dont l'objectif est de multiplier les
heures à l'occasion de manifestations où
l'objectif n'est pas de revendiquer au
côté des manifestants ce que les
manifestants eux-mêmes revendiquent mais
d'organiser les conditions de
l'affrontement de la confrontation et
de la mise en cause des forces de
l'ordre après qu'on s'en est pris à elle
et parfois aussi aux personnes et au
bien et c'est ce que nous avons vécu
dans un certain nombre de manifestations
tout au long de l'année 2016 et ce qui
semble perdurer dans la période actuelle
qui justifie la création de cette
commission d'enquête que savions-nous
sur ces groupes violents
d'abord qu'il n'était pas tous composés
de citoyens français qui pouvaient
l'être de citoyens européens appartenant
des mouvements d'extrême gauche
notamment et pas seulement et que ces
groupes
avec commis un certain nombre
d'exactions à l'occasion de grands
sommets internationaux ou de grandes
manifestations
européennes exposition universelle à gel
ou ailleurs et que l'organisation de ces
groupes qui communiquait entre eux
conduisaient des individus
étrangers européens mais pas seulement
affranchi à franchir la frontière de
notre pays à la veille des grandes
manifestations avec des contacts
nationaux
qui permettait d'organiser leur venue et
de fomenter des violences
auxquelles nous avons assisté
la deuxième chose donc ça ce sont des
éléments dont je me souviens qui nous
étaient communiqués par les services de
renseignement et qui nous a conduit à
prendre un certain nombre de
dispositions que je rappellerai deuxième
élément ils étaient de plus en plus
nombreux et les collaborateurs du
ministère de l'Intérieur notamment au
moment des manifestations sur la loi
travail
m'indiquer que le nombre
de ceux qu'on appelait black bloc de
façon un peu générique et imprécise
était de plus en plus significatif et
qu'il prenait place dans les
manifestations au milieu des
manifestants et que pendant les
manifestations on les voyait s'équiper
des moyens qui étaient destinés à
affronter à organiser la confrontation
avec les forces de l'ordre et qu'à ce
moment-là il était extraordinairement
difficile contenu positionnement qui
était le leur de les séparer des
manifestants qui manifestaient
sincèrement et sans aucune volonté de
violence et que ça rendait les
interpellations et l'établissement de
l'ordre relativement difficile
enfin le troisième élément par de la le
nombre et la provenance c'est l'extrême
violence
ces groupes sont des groupes d'une
extrême violence
et qui arrive avec des équipements
boules de pétanque
des projectiles qui sont destinés à
atteindre pour les blessés peut-être
même davantage les forces de l'ordre et
qui peuvent bien entendu
occasionner dès lors ses individus sont
au milieu des manifestants des
graves troubles alors public avec des
conséquences pour l'intégrité physique
des manifestants qui peuvent être
extrêmement
importantes et donc
les mesures qui ont été prises à ce
moment-là
on consistait à mettre en place des
dispositifs de maintien de l'ordre selon
une méthode et selon des dispositifs qui
étaient
pour ce qui concerne Paris pilotés par
le préfet de police de Paris mais en
étroite relation avec votre serviteur
la doctrine était simple faire en sorte
qui est une totale proportionnalité dans
l'intervention de la force qu'il y est
une nécessité de l'engager car la
désescalade ne suppose pas toujours
l'engagement de la force que nous
puissions au maximum en amont des
manifestations
dialoguées avec les organisateurs des
manifestations pour analyser avec eux la
possibilité par des opérations de
médiation des opérations de préparation
concertées d'éviter que ceux qui
venaient dans l'esprit de perturber ces
manifestations et d'engendrer la
violence puisse être
identifié le plus en amont possible et
si possible contenu
et je vous le dis monsieur le Président
parce que ça peut être utile à votre
commission
j'ai à l'époque demandé au préfet de
police et mes collaborateurs que tu as
la totalité des instructions
relatives à
ces dispositifs d'ordre public face
objet d'ordre d'opérations et de
compte-rendus d'opération que vous
pouvez bien entendu je pense encore
demander
et qui ont pour intérêt de rétablir la
traçabilité de toutes les décisions qui
ont été prises au regard du contexte
auquel nous étions confronté et par
conséquent de mesurer le décalage ou pas
qui peut exister entre les ordres qui
ont été donnés et ce que l'on peut en
dire
parce que après tout la meilleure
manière de mesurer l'attention d'un
administration et de ceux qui sont sa
tête c'est de prendre des ordres
d'opérations de l'époque les comptes
rendus d'opération les rétex et de
regarder très concrètement comment les
opérations ont été conduites elles ont
été conduites dans l'esprit que j'ai
indiqué
compte tenu de l'extrême tension qui
demeurait et qui s'amplifiait
s'intensifier sur des forces de l'ordre
dans lesquels on trouve des agents du
service public sont des agents du
service public les policiers et les
gendarmes dans notre pays qui ont une
caractéristique ces agents du service
public c'est d'être en première ligne au
péril de leur vie pour assurer la
sécurité des Français et notamment la
sécurité de ceux qui manifestent c'est
leur mission et c'est leur obligation
déontologique et leur honneur que de le
faire et il arrive que beaucoup d'entre
eux soient blessés dans le cadre de ces
manifestations et à subir
un sort qui n'est pas particulièrement
enviable ce sont des agents du service
public
moi les agents du service public quel
que soit leur mission et dès lors qu'il
l'a remplissent avec un sens du service
public qui caractérise la plupart de
ceux qui dans la police et dans la
gendarmerie agissent je les respecte
et notamment lorsqu'il perdent leur vie
et se trouve en première ligne pour
assurer la sécurité des Français et
notamment dans une période où je
rappelle que des policiers ont été
assassinés à leur domicile
par des terroristes devant leur enfant
de 3 ans alors je ne dis pas ça du tout
pour susciter de l'émotion ou appeler la
moi mais je le dis simplement par esprit
du 6 parce que la théorisation de la con
substantialité de la violence à la
police quand la police subit cette
violence justifie qu'à un moment donné y
compris dans cet enceinte même si on
exerce plus de responsabilité politique
on puisse rappeler ce qui a été le
sacrifice de ceux qui ont peur dit leur
vie en raison de ce qui était leur
mission de l'uniforme qu'il portait et
de
l'obligation dans laquelle ils sont
trouvés parce que c'était leur honneur
de protéger les Français
donc je profite de cette commission
d'enquête pour le rappeler parce que je
l'ai vécu et que lorsque vous êtes
ministre de l'Intérieur et que vous avez
dans vos équipes dans vos collaborateurs
au fonctionnaires un très grand nombre
d'hommes et de femmes qui subissent ce
sort bien entendu lorsque vous exprimez
sur leur mission vous êtes soumis si
vous avez un minimum de sens de l'État à
une obligation de retenue et lorsque ces
manifestations se produisaient et que
des difficultés intervenez dans
l'exercice de leur mission j'estimais
qu'il était de mon rôle de ne pas les
livrer à la vindicte
de ne pas les protéger lorsque des
fautes étaient commises parce que ce
n'est pas le rôle du ministre de
l'intérieur de faire cela mais d'essayer
d'être républicain et juste
et
l'une des manières de les protéger était
de faire en sorte que ceux qui pouvaient
occasionner des troubles à leur public
au moment des manifestations
et qui était d'identifier comme tel
c'est-à-dire comme des individus connus
des services dangereux venant dans les
manifestations pour écouter occasionner
des troubles soit empêchés par des
mesures de police administrative d'y
venir parce que là aussi qu'ils ont les
choses clairement on ne peut pas à la
fois se battre et c'est légitimes pour
la liberté de manifestation et je suis
de ceux qui sont toujours battus pour
que cette liberté en France qui est
grande et qui repose sur un dispositif
particulier qui est celui de la simple
déclaration de manifestation soit
maintenue on peut pas souhaiter que les
manifestations élues aussi souvent que
ceux qui s'estiment légitimes à
revendiquer
souhaitent les organiser je suis aussi
favorable à ce que cela perdure
souhaitait qu'il n'y ait pas de violence
dans les manifestations et qu'on soit
intraitable avec les fonctionnaires qui
pourraient manquer à leurs obligations
déontologiques
regretter que les policiers ne puissent
pas distinguer par des fautes
professionnalisme ou de formation des
manifestants sincères des casseurs et en
même temps s'indigner que l'on empêche
les casseurs de participer aux
manifestations lorsqu'on sait ce qu'ils
sont par le travail des services de
renseignements et que par une mesure de
police administrative on peut éviter
qu'il n'y participe précisément pour que
les manifestations se passent bien donc
effectivement là aussi j'ai pris mes
responsabilités de mise de l'Intérieur
en liaison avec les services qui
travaillaient au sein du ministère pour
faire en sorte que tous ceux qui étaient
identifiés comme appartenant à des
groupes dont on savait qu'il faut monter
ces opérations ne puisse pas participer
aux manifestations soit interpellés
avant que la manifestation de commence
car cette politique me paraît de nature
à éviter des difficultés
dernier point sur lequel je voudrais
dire un mot
c'est sur ce qui s'est passé à Sylvain
c'est peut-être ce qui s'est passé aussi
à sainte-solide même je suis moins
informé de ce qui s'est passé à
Sainte-Soline
le mystère de l'intérieur n'est pas le
ministère en charge des décisions
relatives aux équipements
qui doivent être créés dans tel ou tel
territoire en raison de
l'évolution de notre agriculture ou de
la conception qu'on peut avoir
des voies qu'elle doit emprunter pour ce
mois dernieriser je dirais même que si
ces équipements ou si ces orientations
sont nature à créer de graves troubles à
l'ordre public dans les réunions
interministérielles ou lorsque le
ministre de l'Intérieur a l'occasion
d'exprimer à ses collègues ce qu'il
pense de ces sujets pour des raisons qui
tiennent à
lucidité qu'il a à l'égard des
événements qui risquent de se produire
il déconseille généralement qu'on
sentait trop longtemps
donc les équipements qui
étaient contestés étaient pas des
équipements de la compétence du
ministère de l'Intérieur et il
appartenait à d'autres administrations
d'y mettre fin s'il le souhaitaient bon
si elle le souhaitait ça n'a pas été le
cas Isa Sivens lorsque le mystère de
l'Intérieur s'est trouvé confronté aux
problèmes de maintien de notre public
j'ai là aussi donné l'instructions
extrêmement claires les instructions
étaient les suivantes 1 éviter
absolument que ceux qui s'incruste dans
des groupes pacifistes et il y avait de
nombreux de nombreux écologistes
spécifistes à civas qui menait un combat
sans le recours à la moindre violence et
qui était autour d'un certain nombre de
grandes fédérations écologistes pour
faire en sorte que ce projet ne se fasse
pas mais en utilisant tous les moyens de
la conviction
échange d'avoir jamais recours à la
violence et mon souhait était d'éviter
que l'arrivée du groupe violent parmi
ces militants n'aboutissent à ce que ces
groupes violents souhaités c'est-à-dire
d'ailleurs à des forces avec les forces
de l'ordre et à des drames et par
conséquent un certain nombre
d'instructions ont été là aussi une
commission d'enquête a été présidée par
Noël ma mère le rapporteur on était
Pascal Popelin les auditions ont eu lieu
les documents étaient communiquaires
rapports étaient rendus donc on sait
exactement sur ce sujet qui a fait quoi
qui a dit quoi on peut ensuite
se mettre à qual tel ou telle
responsable politique
d'assassin on peut se mettre à travestir
la réalité avec un cynisme absolu pour
ce délai beau rôle mais il y a une
réalité et cette réalité elle est dans
les ordres d'opération elle est dans les
consignes qui ont été données elle est
dans les instructions qui ont été
écrites et signés des ministres à
l'époque et comme votre Parlement enfin
votre assemblée et le Parlement a fait
un travail d'enquête extrêmement poussé
sur ces sujets il a été en situation de
reconstituer les ordres qui ont été
donnés à ce moment-là mais ce que révèle
cette affaire et cette tragédie de
silence comme les événements de sainte
solide c'est que nous ne sommes plus
dans une société dans laquelle on peut
par la force
résoudre des difficultés qui suscitent
des passions dans la société dès lors
que l'on n'est pas allé au bout du
dispositif de discussion et de
concertation
et dès lors qu'on n'a pas réussi à
instaurer dans la société des modes de
médiation qui permettent d'installer de
la raison et d'éviter que ce type
d'événement de se produise et
beaucoup de choses ont été dites au
moment de civas qui ont été d'ailleurs
redites au moment de sainte Soline il y
a un processus de prise de décision sur
ces questions qui
ne va pas suffisamment loin dans le
processus de concertation et de
l'association des acteurs
si bien que une fois que la décision est
prise en droit et qu'elle doit par
conséquence imposée parce qu'une
décision prise en droit doit s'imposer
sinon il y a plus de d'état de droits il
y a plus de République nous sommes
confrontés à des tensions qui permettent
à des acteurs d'engager toute une série
d'opérations politiques dont on voit ce
qu'elles sont et à quoi elles cherchent
à aboutir donc
voilà ce que je voulais dire sur ces
sujets qui est le témoignage de ce que
j'ai vécu dans une période qui était
particulièrement difficile et éprouvante
pour les Français et pour les forces de
l'ordre
et je suis prêt bien entendu répondre à
toutes vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le Premier
ministre je vais donc comme prévu passer
la parole à notre rapporteur monsieur
Florent Boudier je vous en prime sur le
rapporteur
donc voilà pardon merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
un grand merci d'avoir accepté cette
audition devant notre commission
d'enquête je pense qu'il était important
que nous puissions bénéficier de votre
expérience elle est grande
en tant que
ministre de l'intérieur et en tant que
bien sûr Premier ministre plusieurs
questions qui seront volontairement
assez larges
la première
est-ce que vous considérez monsieur le
Premier ministre qu'il y a un continuum
au fond entre
l'usage de la conflictualité en
politique
et le recours à des violences de type
matériel voire physique
je pense que c'est un élément sur
lesquels
notre commission
[Musique]
est intéressée d'avoir votre éclairage
votre réflexion
deuxième question
quel regard portez-vous sur la gestion
du maintien de l'ordre à l'occasion de
la période concernée je pense qui est
important puisse nous faire part de la
façon dont vous avez observé le mode de
fonctionnement qu'elle approche vous
avez pu analyse
pu avoir de des prises de décision
des processus de dialogue ou de manque
de dialogue avec les organisations
syndicales ou les organisateurs de
manifestation je pose cette question
parce que vous avez rappelé
la question des interdictions de
manifester
quand vous étiez en responsabilité
et puis troisième question plus précise
vous avez employé le terme de goût ou de
groupe pardon organisé et violent
de quel type de structuration avez-vous
connaissance lorsque vous étiez en
responsabilité
c'est à des points de questionnement
important pour la commission d'enquête
il y a des situations nous notons des
organisations très concrètes très de
terrain notamment à travers la voie
numérique qui les facilite il y a aussi
un centre de retour qui démontre qu'il y
a des phénomènes de solidarisation qu'il
y a des opportunités parfois des
opportunistes délinquants qui sont
d'autres nature mais qui viennent se
greffer assez manifestations violentes
je parle des manifestations de violence
voilà donc à la fois conflictualité et
politique
votre regard sur la gestion du maintien
de l'ordre sachant que cette aléatoire
que vous étiez en responsabilité qui a
été lancée les premières qui ont été
lancées les premières réflexions sur la
modification du schéma national de
matière de l'ordre et puis cette
question de l'organisation des
groupuscules qu'elle était les
informations dont vous disposiez si vous
pouvez nous en faire part monsieur le
Premier ministre
première question
est conflictualité politique la
conflictualité des consubstantielles à
la démocratie
la démocratie c'est un régime de
conflits entre des hommes et des femmes
des organisations qui font pas la même
chose sur des sujets et qui organise
entre eux une discussion qui peut avoir
une dimension conflictuelle et que l'on
appelle le débat
donc moi je ne suis pas inquiet de la
conflictualité parce que précisément si
la démocratie parle le moyen de l'État
droit définit des règles
dans lesquelles nous sommes censés nous
reconnaître c'est précisément parce que
ces règles sont la garantie que nous
pourrons nous opposer sans que la
société devienne un monde où
l'affrontement aboutit à la violence de
tous contre tous donc la démocratie est
un système de conflictualité c'est un
système d'opposition de groupes qui sur
des sujets divers ne pense pas la même
chose et ça n'est pas grave que cela
soit le cas ça n'est pas grave aussi
longtemps que ceux qui s'opposent de
façon parfois dure et dans l'histoire de
notre pays dans le tournant de son
histoire sous la Troisième République
notamment quand on regarde les débats
qui ont pu se produire au moment de
l'instauration de la laïcité
au moment de la première guerre mondiale
il y a une très grande conflictualité
très grande violence parfois même dans
l'hémicycle
mais il y avait chez les républicains
l'idée que ceux qui les rassemblés
étaient plus fort que ce qu'il est
divisé et que la manière dont il se
diviser
devait les conduire à affirmer avec
d'autant plus de force se rattachement à
la règle commune aux institutions à la
règle de droit que précisément ils
étaient parfois dans une opposition
frontale des uns par rapport aux autres
donc la conflictualité n'est pas le
problème le problème c'est l'extrémisme
c'est à dire le moment où
le désir de la conflictualité
et la conflictualité non pas les guerres
de ceux qui ne pensent pas comme ça
ouais mais des institutions elles-mêmes
aboutit à préconiser
qu'on sorte des principes de l'État de
droit et de la République telle qu'on
fonctionne pour instaurer un autre type
de dispositif qui entretient avec le
droit à une relation d'une autre nature
donc moi je ne pense pas qu'il est une
mauvaise République
il y a la République dans ces
institutions et si l'on veut que la
République dans ces institutions
fonctionnent et que la conflictualité en
son sein soit possible il faut pas
remettre en cause de façon outrancière
et systématiquement transgressive les
règles qui fondent la République
parce que sinon ce n'est plus la
conflictualité c'est l'affrontement de
tout ce qu'on peut tous
et c'est l'extrémisme
deuxième question
pour ce qui concerne
les opérations telles qu'elles ont été
conduites est-ce qu'il y a un continuum
ou pas
il y a des éléments de continuité dans
la manière dont le gouvernement conduit
sa politique à l'égard des forces de
sécurité intérieure après une d'un début
de quinquennat de premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron ou des effectifs
étaient là mais les moyens dit hors-t2
c'est-à-dire les moyens de
fonctionnement ne l'était pas les choses
ont été depuis établies et je serai
vraiment très malhonnête
intellectuellement si je ne
reconnaissais pas que les effectifs et
les moyens budgétaires pour permettre
aux effectifs de fonctionner normalement
sont présents
je suis dans une opposition
à la majorité actuelle c'est pas un
mystère mais c'est pas une opposition
qui consiste à raconter n'importe quoi
sur tous les sujets
en dépit de ce qu'il a la réalité des
faits parce que ça c'est pas c'est pas
opposé c'est
garé
début du quinquennat de premier
quinquennat il manquait des moyens hors
T2 au moment du plan de relance ils ont
été rétablis c'était une faute de ne pas
les donner et mais le fait qu'il y ait
aujourd'hui les effectifs et les moyens
budgétaires doit être reconnu tout
simplement parce que c'est vrai
est-ce que sur la politique du maintien
de l'ordre les choses sont faites de
manière identique
il y a des
des décisions qui ont été prises par
actuelle ministre de l'Intérieur
notamment au moment des émeutes dans la
technique du maintien de l'ordre que
j'ai considéré comme efficace et je ne
voyais pas ce que l'on pouvait faire
autrement ce qu'on pouvait faire
d'autres lorsqu'on avait le sens de
l'état des responsabilités mais il y a
des signaux qui ont été envoyés parfois
à la police que je n'aurais pas donné et
que je considère comme
tout à fait contraire à la conception
que je peux avoir de la relation
de l'État aux forces de sécurité dans
les périodes de tension
je pense que la police ne peut pas
envoyer le signal elle-même qu'elle
s'estime au dessus des principes de
l'État de droit
et un policier
est un citoyen comme un autre
et qui est soumis au même règle que les
autres citoyens
et les déclarations qui ont été faites
par un certain nombre responsables du
ministère de l'Intérieur au moment où il
y avait des problèmes de maintien de
l'ordre sur le fait que alors que la
justice faisait son travail on en
commentait les décisions ce sont des
mots que je n'aurais pas utilisé des
décisions que je n'aurais pas
entérinaire enfin des discours que je
n'aurais pas entériné et des propos je
n'aurais pas laissé tenir de la même
manière quand les policiers vont
manifester devant la place Vendôme à
l'époque j'étais mise de l'intérieur il
n'était pas accompagné de mon soutien
peut comprendre qui est des
interrogations entre la police et la
justice entre les magistrats et ceux qui
sont en charge des forces de sécurité
intérieure mais dans un état de droit
la police et la justice ça fait bloc
et si ça fait pas bloc c'est qu'il y a
un problème très sérieux et donc on peut
pas encourager les policiers et les
manifester contre les magistrats et même
si ça vous fait mal voir des policiers
et ça n'a pas
contribué à rendre les relations entre
les organisations syndicales de la
police et moi nécessairement facile au
moment où je prenais ces positions mais
je les ai prises
troisième élément est-ce que le
processus de désescalade
était l'image qui prévalait au moment où
vous voyez les quoi des certains moyens
à Sainte-Sophie je ne suis pas sûr que
ce que cette image était envoyée à ce
moment-là même si je conviens que le
contexte à sainte-solide était
extrêmement difficile et que il était
sans doute
compliqué de laisser le désordre
s'instaurer et la violence se
développait sans réagir donc je ne suis
pas en adéquation et en accord avec tout
ce qui peut se faire à tout moment mais
globalement je considère que dans un
contexte extraordinairement difficile et
sur les sujets fondamentaux les
décisions qui devaient être prises l'ont
été
et que en matière de sécurité intérieure
comme matière de défense il doit y avoir
un minimum de consensus entre les forces
politiques du pays lorsque le pays
menace peut se fragmenter et de ce
fractionner votre troisième question
concernée
l'organisation je me suis exprimé sur ce
sujet moi toutes les informations dont
je disposais à l'époque montrer qu'il y
avait
des individus appartenant des
organisations extrémistes qui
souhaitait à l'occasion de toutes les
grandes manifestations internationales
quel qu'en soit la nature venir en
perturber le cours j'avais notamment
énormément d'informations des services
de renseignement de la structuration de
ces groupes en vue de l'organisation du
plus grand désordre au moment de la
Conférence sur le climat ce qui m'a
conduit à prendre des mesures de police
administrative dont on s'est empressé
d'expliquer quelles étaient destinées à
empêcher des manifestants écologiques
manie de manifester à Paris pendant la
COP 21 c'était pas du tout cela ce qui
était visé par les interdictions de
manifester n'était pas gentiment
écologiste c'était des individus
violents identifiés comme tel par nos
services de renseignement et ceux des
autres pays qui agissaient deux concerts
en se parlant qui appartenait à des
organisations
agrégées et qui avait pour objectif de
créer le désordre le plus grand en
mobilisant la violence la plus assumée
et ceci s'est produit en non seulement
dans un certain nombre de capital
européennes ça s'est produit également
aux États-Unis avec
violence qui aboutit à des morts et
ça conduit à une coopération très forte
elle est entre les services
d'enseignement européen à ce moment-là
pour éviter que ces groupes ne
prospèrent et se capitalisent
merci beaucoup monsieur le Premier
ministre je vous propose de passer aux
questions des membres de la commission
donc je rappelle que principe c'est de
limiter le temps de la question à deux
minutes donc
deux minutes donc monsieur Mathieu je
vous baisse la parole et donc j'invite
les collègues qui souhaitent intervenir
de se manifester pour que je puisse
évidemment leur passer la parole donc
monsieur Mathieu je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président je vais
essayer sur des choses aussi complexes
de poser une question en deux minutes
vous avez évoqué la mise en oeuvre de la
RGPP bon c'était suivi par la map action
publique 2022 et combien ça coûtait en
terme d'effectif au forces
sachant que les deux grands leviers du
maintien de l'ordre quand même c'est
soit la force soit la mobilité les deux
mixer le fait d'enlever des effectifs
annuels à la mobilité et a donc renforcé
le tropisme force est-ce que vous pensez
que à partir du moment où on a commencé
à tailler dans les dépenses publiques
force de maintien de y compris c'est là
qu'on a commencé à voir le mouvement de
militarisation en matériel et en
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre deuxième
question il y a eu pas mal d'unités de
type bac déployées depuis quelques
années sur les manifestations ce qui
n'est pas le cas avant c'était une
grande nouveauté
également sans doute pour compenser la
faiblesse des effectifs mais également
pour faire de l'interpellation vous avez
ce qui c'est la question des
manifestants dangereux ce qu'on a pu
constater c'est que l'attitude de ces
unités et leur équipement LBD flash-ball
avant
l'équipement de ces unités et leur
attitude qui étaient une attitude
d'interpellation donc qui était pas dans
la des escalade a pu contribuer à
renforcer une certaine hostilité
systématique à l'égard des manifestants
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que ça pu
mener à dresser un cadre de violence
disproportionnées envers les
manifestants y compris ceux qui sont
totalement pacifiques je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur Mathieu je vous
repasse la parole monsieur le Premier
ministre
bien merci Monsieur député pour cette
question
qui montre toute la complexité du sujet
lorsque lorsqu'on est en situation par
ses responsabilités ministérielles
d'assurer la sécurité de manifestation
il y a des groupes violents
bon d'abord la révision générale des
politiques publiques c'est 2007 2012
c'est pas après
après elle est corrigée
2007-2012 c'est moins 13000
donc moi je peux vous expliquer ce que
j'ai fait comme ministre de l'Intérieur
à l'époque où manomé on a créé 9000
postes dans Créer neuf une poste c'est
pas supprimer des postes c'est en créer
et lorsque si on a créé la pilote
comment non non il y a pas si non non
non non monsieur le député vous avez un
rapport qui a été fait par Madame non
non il y a un rapport qui a fait qui
était fait par Madame rabot en
2017 qui est un rapport extrêmement bien
fait qui a été fait dans un parce que
une femme extrêmement sérieuse et ce
rapport a été fait je crois d'ailleurs
que vous vous avez dû le dire à une ou
deux reprises et vous avez raison et de
lui reconnaître ses qualités ce rapport
a été fait en liaison avec la Cour des
comptes
et les chiffres sont extraordinairement
précis donc si ce dont vous disposez
sont ceux que vous me dites c'est que ce
ne sont pas les bons et si vous me
laissez une adresse mail je vais vous
faire passer le rapport de Madame rabot
ça va contribuer à approfondir l'amitié
que vous avez pour elle il est
extrêmement précis qualitatif et
incontestable donc nous en avons créé
9000 mais nous n'avons pas créé que 9000
postes nous avons augmenté de 20% les
crédits hors T2 de la police et de la
gendarmerie pendant la période ce qui
est également dans le rapport
parlementaire en question parce que la
diminution de 17% des crédits hors T2
pendant la période 2007-2012 avait été
extraordinairement préjudiciable bon
fonctionnement des forces
donc voilà quelle est la réalité
maintenant quand vous regardez les
conséquences de la déflation des
effectifs des forces spécialisées dans
le maintien d'ordre
c'est-à-dire escadron de gendarmerie
mobile et Compagnie républicaine de
sécurité et que vous constatez la
difficulté dans laquelle sont ses forces
de remplir les missions de maintien de
l'ordre qui ne sont pas des missions
d'interpellation
et bien vous êtes obligé d'avoir recours
à d'autres forces lorsque vous allez
manifestations multiples nombreuses avec
des individus violents c'est les
bacs ce sont les compagnies
d'intervention
tout simplement parce que si vous ne
mettez pas le minimum d'effectif en face
de ceux qui sont là pour créer des
troubles importants vous êtes confrontés
à des difficultés très grandes
crée les conditions de la désescalade
mais lorsque vous avez des individus par
centaines
appelées black bloc dans les
manifestations viennent casser si vous
ne les interpellez pas
alors vous donnez le sentiment de
l'impuissance
et vous créez les conditions du désordre
plus grand et d'ailleurs je suis
convaincu que les mêmes qui regrettent
l'intervention de ses forces
lorsqu'elles interpellent
serait les premiers à qualifier
l'incompétence de la police si elle
n'intervenait pas pour mettre fin à ses
désordres immenses
parce qu'il existe monsieur député vous
le savez bien des acteurs politiques qui
considèrent que quoi que fasse la police
elle a toujours tort
et qui prennent argument de tous les
manquements de toutes les difficultés
etc pour en faire un argument
de condamnation des forces de l'ordre
dans leur capacité leurs compétences etc
donc quand vous êtes ministre vous devez
aussi tenir compte de ça parce que la
crédibilité de l'État dans son action
elle dépend de l'efficacité de son
action au moment où celle-ci s'effectue
dans un contexte de très grande tension
vous parlez de militarisation
des forces de sécurité intérieure
moi je n'ai pas senti lorsque j'étais
ministre de l'Intérieur que les forces
de l'ordre se militariser
j'ai même senti parce que nous étions
encore une époque où la gendarmerie
venait d'intégrer le ministère de
l'Intérieur et où il fallait articuler
l'intervention
de la police et de la gendarmerie une
tendance à la délimitarisation des
forces de sécurité intérieure pour des
raisons qui tenaient à la cohabitation
des cultures et la nécessité de faire en
sorte que ces deux cultures très
différentes finissent par se dépasser
pour faire en sorte que une culture
nouvelle républicaine des forces de
l'ordre qui qui soient possibles en
revanche je pense que la volonté à un
moment donné de faire du ministère de
l'Intérieur seulement un ministère de la
Sécurité
à l'américaine de faire des forces de
sécurité intérieure
une place de grand FBI et la réforme qui
a été conduite sur le renseignement à
travers la fusion des renseignements
généraux et de la DST pour créer la
desscri qui empruntait également la même
philosophie a fait du mystère de
l'Intérieur non plus le mystère de la
sécurité mais non plus le mystère de
l'État c'est à dire le ministère à la
fois de la sécurité des libertés
publiques des territoires des valeurs
républicaines mais davantage un
ministère de la Sécurité qui a pu donner
le sentiment de l'évolution que vous
décrivez et par ailleurs j'ai
personnellement beaucoup regretté et
d'ailleurs le rapport parlementaire fait
par Pascal Popelin pointesta juste titre
j'ai beaucoup regretté que le ministère
de l'Intérieur se coupe de toute la
réflexion des universitaires des
chercheurs qui travaillaient parfois de
façon critique à l'égard du ministère de
l'intérieur mais dans les réflexions les
thèses les
études méritaient d'être encouragées et
financé par le ministère de l'Intérieur
et d'ailleurs à la fin de mon passage
place Beaubourg j'ai ré alloué des
sommes certains nombre de thèses sur ces
sujets parce que je pense que le mystère
de l'intérieur ne peut pas se couper du
monde de la recherche sur des questions
si sensibles
merci beaucoup monsieur le Premier
ministre nous avons également une
demande de Monsieur Oudoul je vous passe
la parole ensuite monsieur Vico puis
monsieur taverne et Monsieur Mendes donc
monsieur Odoul je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur Monsieur le Premier Ministre
j'aimerais déjà vous remercier pour
l'hommage que vous avez rendu aux forces
de l'ordre aux agents du service public
de la sécurité intérieure vous avez
rappelé le drame de Magnanville et
l'attentat contre deux policiers
commis par un terroriste islamiste vous
aviez aussi connu lors de vos
responsabilités le drame de ces
policiers attaqués au cocktail Molotov à
Viry-Châtillon gravement brûlé et je
pense qu'à l'heure où certains hausse
marcher en crachant sur nos forces de
l'ordre et nos policiers je pense que
c'est bien que un ancien Premier
ministre rappelle
le soutien que l'on doit au fort de
l'ordre au gendarmes aux policiers qui
prennent des risques inconsidérés chaque
jour pour assurer l'ordre public
je voulais vous demander également à
l'aune de votre regard de votre
expérience et de certaines de vos
citations
ce que vous pensez du maintien de
l'ordre en 2016 le 15 mai après les
événements de Rennes vous aviez dit le
maintien de l'ordre est plus difficile
qui ne l'a jamais été continue votre
expérience et de votre regard sur la
situation sur la situation actuelle
est-ce que vous jugez que c'est encore
plus difficile aujourd'hui que la
situation a empiré quelle était au
moment
de 2016 et des manifestations contre la
loi el khomri par ailleurs vous avez
parlé
du nécessaire consensus des forces
politiques autour de la sécurité
intérieure est-ce que vous jugez que
ceux qui veulent désarmer la police ceux
qui parlent à tout bout de champ de
violences policières ceux qui considère
que la police est raciste vous
considérez que ce sont des extrémistes
vous considérez qu'ils sont hors du
champ républicain et considérez-vous
qu'il porte une lourde responsabilité
dans les attaques régulières dans les
manifestations violentes et dans les
menaces qui pèsent sur les forces de
l'ordre en France je remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le Premier je
vous repasse la parole
je pense que les opérations de maintien
de l'ordre aujourd'hui s'effectue dans
un contexte différent de celui que j'ai
connu pour des raisons qui tiennent au
fait que la menace héroïste n'est pas au
même niveau qu'elle ne l'était à
l'époque que les effectifs ont été
réhaussées que des moyens
supplémentaires ont été donnés la police
depuis de nombreuses années
que le la réforme du renseignement
permet de prendre en amont des
événements susceptibles de présenter des
troupes gravats dans public des
décisions pertinentes et opportunes et
donc je pense que tout ce contexte
nouveau qui résulte de la volonté
politique de donner aux forces de
sécurité intérieure les moyens
d'accomplir leurs missions
convenablement créer un contexte
différente celui que j'ai pu connaître à
une époque où nous étions encore
confrontés à la réalité de la RGPP à une
menace terroriste élevée et les forces
de sécurité étaient soumises à une
pression très grande
est-ce que cela signifie que la violence
a diminué la violence
à l'occasion des manifestations et la
violence d'un certain nombre de groupes
extrémistes dont je ne pense pas qu'elle
est diminuée je pense qu'elle a plutôt
augmenté et si je m'exprime avec mesure
sur la science de mes successeurs c'est
tout simplement parce que je considère
que cette tâche de maîtrise de l'ordre
public dans un contexte de violence
accrue et bien entendu très très
compliqué et que le rôle d'un
responsable politique ce n'est pas de
compliqué la tâche de ceux qui utilisent
bien dans un contexte difficile dans
tous les cas ce n'est pas la conception
aujourd'hui troisième élément
[Musique]
il peut y avoir bien entendu des fautes
dans la police
il peut y avoir des policiers qui
manquent à leurs obligations
théontologiques
il peut y avoir des policiers qui
tiennent des propos discriminatoires
racistes et c'est inacceptable et il
faut à ce moment-là que des sanctions
soient immédiatement prises et que les
inspections dont c'est le rôle et les
responsabiles hiérarchiques dont c'est
l'honneur prennent des dispositions qui
permettent de faire en sorte que les
manquements soient immédiatement
condamnés et réprimer et d'ailleurs ils
le sont la plupart du temps
mais le fait qu'il y ait des individus
qui manquent à leurs obligations et qui
pour cela doivent être sanctionnés ne
signifient en aucun cas qui a une
consubstantialité de la violence à la
police et cela ne signifie pas que la
police est raciste par nature et cela
signifie encore moins qu'on lui donne
des ordres qui l'autoriserait à se
comporter de la sorte
et laisser à croire cela
alors que ce n'est pas la réalité c'est
organisé volontairement et délibérément
la suspicion la défiance et
potentiellement le ressentiment et la
violence une partie de la société les
garde des forces de l'ordre alors que
tout ce que nous devons faire en ayant
un très haut niveau d'exigence à l'égard
des forces de l'or et notamment un très
haut niveau d'exigence déontologique en
étant intraitable sur cette question
c'est d'apporter la démonstration que la
promesse républicaine y compris
lorsqu'il que cela concerne les forces
de l'ordre est intacte et que ceux qui
portent la responsabilité politique
entendent créer des conditions pour que
cette promesse soit inaltérable voilà
c'est que je crois être la
responsabilité d'un républicain
face aux difficultés auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés parfois et qui
conduisent une violence extrême à
s'exprimer sans limite
merci beaucoup monsieur Vico je vous en
prie
merci monsieur le Président et merci
Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour votre
exposé qui allie à la fois le côté
synthétique mais aussi de très grandes
précisions moi j'aurai une question
relativement simple et en deux parties
concernant la formation des policiers
vous avez évoqué l'évolution des
contextes de manifestation de plus
grande violence de la part de certains
manifestants de plus grandes difficultés
à maintenir l'ordre est-ce que vous
pensez que la formation des policiers
aujourd'hui est totalement adaptée à ce
nouveau contexte est-ce que cette
formation devrait être
moduler
préciser sur certains points il y a
l'apport des sciences sociales que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure et sur la
notion de désescalade j'ai le sentiment
que cette notion allait davantage
naturellement systématiquement intégrée
dans la formation d'autres policiers en
Europe est-ce que cette des escalade
devrait être
mieux appréhendé par les policiers plus
systématiquement enseigné et plus
systématiquement
mis en oeuvre sur le terrain on a une
police aujourd'hui qui est assez
systématiquement une police
d'intervention et quand je dis police
intervention ça ne signifie pas police
violente bien entendu mais une police
d'intervention cette notion des escalade
c'est-à-dire deux volonté quoi qu'il
arrive et avant tout de faire en sorte
que les manifestations soient apaisées
et non pas de simple maintien de l'ordre
dans la manifestation est-ce que cette
notion des escalade devrait être selon
vous davantage apprise intégrer par nos
policiers
merci beaucoup le choix passe la parole
pour la formation c'est vraiment la
pierre angulaire d'une police
républicaine c'est fondamental qui est
un dispositif de formation complet
approfondie doté de moyens et continue
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
alors que la direction d'administration
centrale de la formation de la police
avait été supprimée en 2008 dans le cas
de la RGPP elle a été recrée en 2015 et
d'ailleurs elle a été recrée au terme
d'échange approfondie entre
un de mes prédécesseurs lointains
ayant eu toujours des idées assez
précises sur ce sujet dont il est venu
très vite me parler qui ont inspiré une
grande partie de mon action je le dis
bien volontiers parce que ce qu'il m'a
indiqué et qui résultait de son
expérience m'est apparu comme frappé de
beaucoup de pertinence et donc je me
suis inspiré de ce qu'il m'a dit pour
faire ce que j'avais à faire
deuxièmement
pour ce qui concerne les forces en
charge du maintien de l'ordre la
formation doit être plus poussée
encore qu'elle ne l'est pour
les autres
structures ou services pour des raisons
qui tiennent au niveau d'exposition à la
difficulté de manœuvre et au risque qui
s'attachent à l'intervention des
policiers en opération de maintien de
l'ordre et d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle moi je ne suis pas favorable à
ce que les opérations de maintiennent
l'ordre soient conduites par d'autres
forces que les forces spécialisées
et si l'on doit adjoindre au forces
spécialisées des forces d'intervention
pour permettre des interpellations elles
doivent bénéficier du même type de
formation que les forces spécialisées et
intervenir dans une étroite relation
avec les forces spécialisées sous le
contrôle de l'autorité civile pour faire
en sorte c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure que ce qui relève de
l'interpellation ne viennent pas opérer
ce qui relève de l'efficacité
du rapport de force dans les opérations
de maintien de l'ordre
est-ce que cette niveau de formation est
aujourd'hui suffisant je ne sais pas
comment il a été actualisé mais je me
souviens qu'à l'époque j'étais mise de
l'Intérieur à Saint-Astier les escadrons
de gendarmerie mobiles devaient subir
une actualisation un stage de formation
tous les 32 mois je considère que
c'était insuffisant contenu du niveau de
violence qui montait
et de la nécessaire adaptation des
conditions du maintien de l'ordre à
cette violence toujours plus importante
donc la position qui est la mienne c'est
qu'il y a sans doute beaucoup de choses
à approfondir à améliorer dès lors qu'on
part du principe que sont les forces
spécialisées qui doivent intervenir pour
améliorer la formation
ensuite sur la formation des policiers
en général
[Musique]
il y a une décision de diminution de la
durée de formation des policiers de 6
mois je crois au début du quinquennat
précédent
on l'a dit que cette décision
s'inspirait d'une édition que j'avais
prise moi-même ce n'est pas exact moi
j'avais dans un contexte où il fallait
intégrer rapidement des policiers dans
les effectifs pris la décision que nous
pouvions réduire pour intégrer
rapidement
certains policiers dans les cadres la
formation applicable
aux AGS
qui étaient déjà dans les services
police qui
avait déjà fréquenté des activités de
sécurité et dont la durée pour une
promotion seulement une promotion a été
réduite de six mois une promotion pas de
policier une promotion
d'adjoint sécurité bon donc moi je pense
qu'il faut faire très attention à la
formation qu'il faut une formation
initiale longue et une formation
continue permanente et une formation
spéciale pour les forces de sécurité
intégrant les éléments bien entendu de
la désescalade
merci beaucoup monsieur taverne je vous
en prie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur le Premier ministre
comme disait mon collègue Julien audou
je voudrais également vous remercier
pour l'hommage que vous avez rendu aux
policiers et aux gendarmes qui le
méritent sincèrement je rappelle que
lors d'un dernier sondage
presque 80% des Français ont une bonne
opinion
des forces de sécurité intérieure et il
y en a assez d'entendre une certaine
classe politique faire le procès à
charge des policiers des gendarmes des
policiers municipaux alors que c'est
même responsaboliques ne connaissent
absolument rien
ils ne connaissent pas les conditions de
travail des policiers qui sont de plus
en plus difficiles on parle de
militarisation alors que on confond
l'équipement la catégorie ce qui montre
une nouvelle fois la maturisme et la
méconnaissance de certains
donc en fait
également j'aurais deux questions parce
que la troisième ça concernait la
formation La formation des policiers
puisque le président de la République a
annoncé que en 2021 quand il était à
l'école de police de Roubaix que 50% du
temps de service des policiers seraient
confronté serait pardon
concerné par la par la formation
[Musique]
continue ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
concernant les moyens intermédiaires
puisque
nous avons été à Sainte-Souline et les
gendarmes d'ailleurs pas que les
gendarmes ne se sentent solide les
policiers également qui sont en charge
du maintien de l'ordre nous ont dit que
malheureusement de plus en plus de
moyens intermédiaires leur avaient été
retiré ce qui avait incontestablement
une conséquence sur les moyens
d'intervention donc je voudrais savoir
ce que vous pensez notamment du retrait
de certaines grenades en général de
gendarmerie à Sainte-Soline nous disait
que il avait une problématique dans la
ligne de zéro à 30 mètres puisque les
les manifestants armés de mâcher de
boules de pétanque avait réussi à venir
au contact donc est-ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui il devrait y avoir une
réflexion sur l'attribution de nouveaux
moyens intermédiaires pour faire face à
cette à cette violence et ensuite
concernant la Cour des comptes vous avez
évoqué la Cour des comptes tout à
l'heure avec des chiffres précis la Cour
des comptes son dernier rapport évoque
également une vague de démission dans
les forces de l'ordre 15000 chez les
gendarmes et Eddy Mitch et les policiers
donc est-ce que cette vague de démission
vous inquiète et selon vous quel serait
les mesures à prendre pour réarmer les
policiers
face à aujourd'hui malheureusement une
baisse de vocation quand on voit les
critiques d'une certaine classe
politique la violence exercée contre ses
forces de l'ordre aujourd'hui on voit
beaucoup de policiers de gendarmes
totalement démotivés merci
c'est le premier ministre je vous
repasse la parole et puis ensuite je
passerai aussi la parole à Monsieur
Mendes qu'il avait également demandé
ce député là aussi enfin je veux dire on
tient pas des discours en fonction de
ces interlocuteurs mais de ses
convictions c'est moi qui ai supprimé à
Salon d'art intermédiaire
et je les ai supprimés parce que je
considérais que elles avaient eu des
conséquences extrêmement graves c'est
moi qui supprimer les grenades
offensives après si vinces
ce que je considère que une arme
un moyen qui est utilisé par des
policiers et que casionnent une telle
tragédie ou des gendarmes ne peut pas
être utilisé une seconde fois donc je
l'ai fait pour les grenades de Francis
je l'ai fait pour des grenades de
désencerclement dont j'ai fait détruire
plusieurs stocks lorsque j'ai constaté
que l'utilisation de ces grenades avait
dans des manifestations où effectivement
des individus violents avaient tenté
d'agir eu des conséquences et des
blessures importantes d'occasionner des
blessures importantes sur des personnes
parce que la police républicaine
elle peut pas maintenir l'ordre par le
la mobilisation de moyens qui ont des
conséquences sur des manifestants du
type de sel tragique qui ont prévalué ça
moi comme ancien ministre de l'intérieur
comme de l'intérieur républicain je ne
peux pas le considérer et donc c'est moi
qui ai pris ces décisions là et donc si
les gendarmes qui vous ont interpellés
sont allés au bout de leur raisonnement
et s'ils ont se souvient des choses ils
auraient dû m'incriminer en fait parce
que c'est moi qui a pris ses décisions
la même manière je considère que
l'utilisation d'un certain nombre de
dispositifs comme les lanceurs de balles
de défense ne peuvent pas être utilisés
dans des manifestations par n'importe
quel service de la police en tir tendu
sans formation sans condition essayer
pour moi ce sont les forces spécialisées
qui peuvent les utiliser et dans des
conditions d'utilisation extrêmement
rigoureuses appelant un niveau de
formation élevé et donc le policier doit
être en situation de rendre compte à
tout moment
dans une policier ces policiers aux
gendarmes donc
la police républicaine est une police
que l'on ne peut pas désarmer mais que
l'on ne peut pas armer par des moyens
des taux dont on connaît les
conséquences quand on le fait bon j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour faire une petite
parenthèse sur le permis de tuer comme
attribue
j'ai vécu les événements que vous savez
mon du terrorisme au moment de
Magnanville au moment de Viry-Châtillon
il y avait une demande très forte des
policiers de voir leur régime de
légitime défense aligné sur celui des
gendarmes
le régime de victime défense des
gendarmes était à l'origine différente
celui des policiers puisque les
gendarmes intervenaient sur le théâtre
des opérations extérieures comme une
force militaire
mais la jurisprudence avait depuis
longtemps aligné des conditions
d'utilisation des armes des policiers et
des gendarmes et la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme comme
la Cour de cassation avait sur ce sujet
pris des positions et fait naître une
jurisprudence dont j'ai accepté qu'elle
soit intégrée dans la loi
non pas pour ajouter du droit ou créer
les conditions d'un nouveau contexte
juridique mais pour sécuriser par la loi
ce que la jurisprudence avait posé de
principe et que les policiers considérés
dans un contexte où ils se sentait
vulnérables comme insuffisamment
protecteur
j'ai entendu dire que cette loi avait
engendré
nombre de morts supplémentaires
j'en ai j'ai pris cette critique très au
sérieux
et comme des rapports universitaires
faisaient état de statistiques j'ai
demandé au ministre Darmanin d'avoir
l'amabilité de me communiquer les
statistiques du nombre de tirs de la
police et de la gendarmerie depuis cette
loi
le nombre de tirs de la police et de la
gendarmerie depuis cette longue minutes
34 %
le nombre de morts a augmenté pour une
raison qui tient tu as une année
particulière qui l'année 2022 mais il
ira m'expliquer comment on peut imputer
à une loi un nombre de morts
supplémentaires avec un nombre de tirs
qui diminue
c'est donc il y a un autre sujet qui
peut relever de la formation qui peut
relever du contexte etc
et je le dis alors présentation
nationale j'ai pas l'occasion de venir
souvent vous voir non pas que je le
regrette c'est je ne suis plus dans la
vie politique donc je n'ai plus de
raison d'être là mais comment peut-on
imaginer
dans la République
caminis quelle que soit sa sensibilité
politique
puisse de façon inconsciente faire
adopter un texte de loi dans l'objectif
et de conduire la police ou la
gendarmerie à utiliser leur arme sans
considération de la vie de ceux qui sont
censés protéger c'est quand même très
curieux d'en arriver à te dire ce type
de raisonnement alors même
que le texte que
l'on appelle habitué a été adoptée dans
les conditions que je viens de dire et
contient les dispositions que je viens
de rappeler je profite de la séance pour
pour le dire
parce qu'il y a un compte rendu nous
compte rendu c'est toujours utile
pour établir la traçabilité des faits
les propos
merci beaucoup donc je passe la parole à
Monsieur Mendès
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre je me permets de
refaire rapidement un point ce que je
regardais cet été quelques documentaires
qui sont très intéressants justement sur
le développement de l'anarchie des Black
Blocs et tous ces sujets un peu partout
dans le monde et on se rend compte qu'en
France majoritairement la doctrine de
maintiendlord a beaucoup évolué depuis
1789 c'est un travail de fond qui avait
été fait d'ailleurs vous étiez venu à la
dernière commission d'enquête sur le
maintien de l'ordre en 2020
non non rassurez-vous on sait que vous
êtes bien plus jeune que ça vous étiez
déjà venu en 2020 justement sur cette
commission d'enquête sur le
maintiendlord vous avez été déjà très
franc et très direct et ça nous avait
fait du bien justement dans ce rapport
d'avoir vos propos on a pu voir cette
dérive qui s'était calmée dans les
années 80-90 ou là les manifestations je
crois qu'on peut tous être d'accord et
c'est historique ça a été montré pas de
mort pas de dérive très peu de
problématiques et des syndicats des
partis politiques très fort en termes de
services d'ordre dérive après les années
2000 avec l'arrivée des Black Blocs du
système anticapitaliste qui aujourd'hui
ne se fait plus juste sur ces
manifestations anticapitalistes et
sociales elles vont dans toutes les
manifestations qu'elles soient sur un
1er mai pour accompagner un cortège à la
base qui est syndical et qui est là pour
fait fêter le travail on a des dérives
des Black Blocs on l'a vécu sur Emmanuel
Macron dès le premier mandat vous l'avez
vécu aussi après la loi travail donc ça
démontre qu'il y a des réalités
aujourd'hui de dérive aussi de des
mécanismes des Black Blocs qui ne
cherchent qu'une seule chose c'est à
tout détruire et on a vu arriver
justement les lbds et grenades en la
plante au début des années 2000 après
les attentats 2001 pour répondre aux
besoins des policiers justement sur la
risque
terroriste et de pouvoir répondre
rapidement s'ils étaient pas
suffisamment armés de pouvoir réagir
rapidement à ses armes aujourd'hui ce
qui nous pose un véritable problème
c'est que le maintien de l'or malgré ce
que certains de mes collègues ont dit
tout à l'heure évoluent selon les
dérives des manifestants et ce ne sont
pas des manifestants qui s'adaptent à la
dérive du maintien de l'ordre vous savez
parler de silence on peut parler
d'autres moments ce qui nous pose un
problème dans cette commission d'enquête
c'est de réussir à démontrer que les
personnes qui étaient présentes et je
vais finir rapidement de se le président
et des présente par exemple à
Sainte-Souline arrivée de partout en
Europe avait été chercher volontairement
par les responsables de ce mouvement de
la Terre et on espère les voir
prochainement pour qu'ils puissent le
confirmer est-ce que pour vous c'est
simplement la dérive de manifestation où
on est sur un système
équivalent du terrorisme utilisé par
certaines formes d'ultra gauche pour
faire tomber le système démocratique et
républicain
ce que je pense c'est qu'il y a des
groupes je l'ai dit déjà tout à l'heure
anciens organisé de plus en plus violent
et dans le but n'est pas l'écologie
dans le but est la destruction d'un
système politique
et
ce type de groupe
hostile aux institutions et désireux de
les voir mettre à mal est une vieille
histoire dans notre pays mais je dois
reconnaître que ça prend une forme
particulièrement intense inquiétante et
qui met l'épreuve les responsables de
l'État et les responsables de la
sécurité publique et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense que sur ces
sujets il faut avoir une position nette
éclair
et qui n'est pas possible d'avoir la
moindre mensuelle étude ou complaisance
à l'égard de ces groupes qui ont fait de
la violence leur cellulite modalités
voilà
la pensée celle-ci
comment non mais le terrorisme moi je
n'utilise pas ce terme là parce que
a été considérable parce que
d'abord le terrorisme a absorbé beaucoup
d'efforts
qu'on aurait pu mobiliser dans le cas du
maintien d'or je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure les forces mobiles ont été
mobilisés au moment d'état d'urgence
dans le contrôle aux frontières pour des
raisons qui tenaient au fait que la
menace héroïque était extrêmement élevée
et le mobilisation des forces de
spécialisées dans le maintien de l'ordre
au moment de la période terroriste sur
un contexte très particulier avec un
niveau de menace élevé a été un élément
extraordinairement perturbateur
pour ceux qui étaient en charge de la
responsabilité du maintien de l'ordre de
la sécurité des Français l'impact a été
très important incontestablement mais
alors que j'étais dans ce contexte là la
doctrine qui était la mienne commise à
l'intérieur c'est les moyens qui sont
donnés aux forces de sécurité intérieure
pour assurer la sécurité et conduire
leur mission doivent l'être dans un
cadre absolument impeccablement
républicain
donc sur les lanceurs de balles de
défense ils doivent être utilisés par
les forces spécialisées dans un contexte
particulier précisé par les textes dans
des conditions de formation très
précises qui permet d'éviter que ces
âmes qui peuvent quand même
occasionner énormément de dommages sur
les individus soient utilisés n'importe
comment le maintien de l'ordre et la
responsabilité de la sécurité le
monopole par la police et la gendarmerie
de la contrainte physique légitime par
l'expression de Monsieur le père ça une
contrepartie
et cette contrepartie elle est
évidemment républicaine c'est-à-dire que
les forces de l'ordre ne peuvent
intervenir que dans le cadre
d'instructions claires de départ
l'autorité civile sous la responsabilité
d'autorité civile
il faut qu'elles interviennent dans un
contexte de strict nécessité que la
proportionnalité soit là que la
déontologie soit rigoureusement
respectée et que les armes et moyens qui
leur sont donnés souhaitent utiliser
par un nombre de forces spécialisées
limitée dans des conditions précisément
définies par les textes et au terme d'un
dispositif de formation de laissant rien
au hasard si possible
merci beaucoup monsieur Bernal ici je
vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président
je vous communiquerai monsieur monsieur
le ministre les chiffres de l'évolution
des équivalents temps plein entre 2012
et 2017 qui correspondent pas à 9000
emplois mais c'est pas très grave
c'est juste que la
précipitation a été de mise à partir de
2015 on comprend bien pourquoi dans les
recrutements avec lave-vaississement de
la formation à 9 mois mais ça vous le
savez bien mieux que moi je voudrais
revenir sur un propos que vous avez tenu
vous avez dit sur les Black Blocs que
vous avez été confronté à une difficulté
c'est qu'ils étaient je prends vos
propos tout à l'heure de plus en plus
nombreux comment vous expliquer cela
comment vous expliquer le fait que alors
que vous étiez en responsabilité que
vous aviez tous les leviers pour faire
face à la situation vous-même vous
constatiez que les Black Blocs étaient
de plus nombreux de plus en plus
nombreux est-ce que cette parce que vous
n'aviez eu un renseignement pas assez
efficace pas assez bon est-ce que les
méthodes qui ont été organisées face à
utiliser face à eux n'était pas
suffisante et ce qui vous a mangé des
choses dans les textes de loi et comment
vous expliquer que le phénomène perdure
alors que ce que vous déplorez a été
visiblement en partie remédier par les
lois successives dont vous dites que
elles sont d'importance et compris sur
les moyens qui ont été donnés aux
policiers aux gendarmes vous aviez dit
vous aviez pas les moyens du fait de la
RGPP précédemment ils ont été remis sur
pied après 2017 selon vos propos et
aujourd'hui ils sont même au-delà et ça
va quand même pas mieux et on a toujours
des difficultés comme samedi dernier
avec des Black Blocs qui s'en prennent à
une voiture de police comment vous
expliquer cet échec
c'est d'abord le député
moi je peux pas considérer que on puisse
qualifier des chèques le fait que les
moyens supplémentaires à louer à la
police au service de renseignement les
actions menées dans le cadre de la
collision en Irak et en Syrie
et permis de diminuer si techniquement
le niveau de monastère oui c'est le
nombre des attentats pour moi ça c'est
pas un échec c'est un succès
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que cette
action a été contestée
à l'époque c'est à dire que lorsque j'ai
mis en place la loi sur le renseignement
il y avait des forces politiques pour
expliquer qu'on mettait en place la
surveillance de masse
que lorsque nous organisions les frappes
de la coalition sur les états majeurs de
daesh araka on nous expliquait que nous
n'avions rien à faire dans cette
coalition et que Monsieur Poutine par le
soutien qui ne portait à Monsieur Bachar
el-Assad serait beaucoup plus efficace
que la Coalition pour éradiquer daesh
j'ai des déclarations très précises
faites par des responsabilités
français éminents qui sont très
promptes à dispenser leur leçon bon donc
c'est je vous raconte tout ça parce que
sont des faits donc nous avons fait tout
ça donc moi je considère pas que c'est
un échec quand vous mettez des moyens
pour la police
de manière à ce qu'elle puisse exercer
convenablement ses missions que vous
donnez les moyens humains et des moyens
budgétaires
et que vous prenez vos responsabilités
au plan international et que vous avez
une diminution de la menace terrorisme
même si vous restez vigilant sur ce
point c'est pas un échec
quand vous êtes attaché au service
public et je sais que vous l'êtes et
qu'un gouvernement donne des moyens
supplémentaires au service public pour
lui permettre d'accomplir ses missions
c'est quand même mieux que quand il
supprime 13000 emplois c'est pas la même
chose donc j'appelle pas un échec le
rétablissement des moyens alloués à une
administration
moyen dont elle a été privée à la fois
sur le plan budgétaire et sur le plan
humain pour lui permettre de remplir
convenablement ses missions et puis on
peut pas vouloir une police républicaine
et quand on crée les conditions par les
effectifs par la déontologie par les
moyens par la formation d'y parvenir
dire on est sur le mauvais chemin parce
que là je le comprends pas quelle est la
cohérence si telle et le raisonnement
ensuite vous me dites les Black Blocs
sont venus en nombre et vous saviez pas
c'est un échec des services de
renseignement mais rassurez-vous les
renseignements m'expliquer qu'il venait
en bloc
et pas toujours habillé en black il me
disait qu'il me détend nombre donc je
savais parfaitement qu'ils arrivaient et
je savais parfaitement par quel
processus il s'agrégé donc les services
de renseignement me prévenaient de ce
qui est allé se produit et il m'a dit
que s'ils étaient de plus en plus
nombreux c'est parce qu'il y avait des
organisations de plus en plus
transnationales appuyé par des
organisations politiques parfois
nationales qui étaient plein de
mensuétude pour ces groupes donc je
savais tout ça il y a aucun défaut de
renseignement à ce moment là j'ai été
parfaitement informé de ce qui se
passait et on peut pas considérer que
ceux qui sont informés de l'arrivée de
ces groupes et qui mobilisent les moyens
de l'État pour éviter qu'ils ne
prospèrent et qu'il ne casse
sont responsables du fait qu'il vienne
alors même qu'on sait que lorsqu'ils
viennent et qu'il casse certains
qui pourraient s'en indigner
explique que la responsabilité de tout
cela et de la police et pas des groupes
en question
l'échec il est là
l'échec il est dans l'incapacité de
qualifier les actes de ces individus
lorsqu'ils sont commis et de ne pas
soutenir les forces de l'ordre lorsque
ces individus en bloquent et en groupe
et en masse arrivent pour casser
rendant d'ailleurs impossible le rôle
des organisations syndicales qui
aspirent à manifester dignement parce
que lorsque j'ai reçu le leader de la
CGT de FO à l'époque pour ré-autoriser
une manifestation parce que je pensais
qu'il fallait non non non une
manifestation c'est moi qui l'ai
autorisé c'est ça la réalité
pourquoi parce que je pense que en
république lorsqu'il y a des tensions
sociales des droits de manifester il
peut pas être remise en cause et ça
c'est soldé et résolu dans mon bureau
mais qu'ai-je entendu des responsables
syndicaux à l'époque j'ai entendu que la
difficulté à laquelle nous nous étions
confrontés face à ces groupes étaient de
nature à plus difficile l'organisation
des manifestations par eux et l'exercice
serein la liberté de manifester à
laquelle les organisations syndicales
sont attachées donc
moi je le vois pas des chèques dans ce
processus et d'ailleurs vous savez très
bien que la plupart des pays européens
sont confrontés à ce problème en
Allemagne il y a eu des actions
extrêmement graves en Italie sans des
produits à gel ou en exposition
universelle donc c'est un phénomène
général c'est un problème extrêmement
grave qui implique une analyse en amont
une mobilisation très forte des pouvoirs
publics ce n'est pas facile
et c'est d'ailleurs parce que je sais
que ce n'est pas un exercice facile et
que
le ministre de l'Intérieur quoi qu'il
fasse à toujours tort que
je suis à l'égard de mes successeurs
d'une extrême pondération
parce que quand on a exercé des
responsabilités politiques et qu'on les
exercer dans les difficultés auxquelles
j'étais confrontées on a un peu de
retenue et de réserve à l'égard de ce
qui vous succèdent parce qu'on connaît
la difficulté de la chose et la
politique dans mon esprit en tous les
cas c'est pas un exercice qui consiste à
atteindre les autres par la convocation
de toutes les outrances pour essayer de
prendre son bénéfice sur le tapis vert
c'est pas ma conception de la politique
voilà donc je ne fais pas ça mais je
comprends que ça soit totalement ringard
que ce soit vraiment totalement vieux
monde totalement fashion totalement en
dehors du temps avec la modernité soit
ailleurs mais moi j'assume cette
position c'est la mienne
merci beaucoup je vais passer la parole
à Madame Marceau et puis je laisserai
évidemment sur le Premier ministre
répondent et puis ensuite Monsieur Le
Fur a également demandé jusqu'à quelle
heure je pense que ce sont les deux
dernières questions donc je pense que
d'ici une dizaine de minutes maximum
voilà madame arsault je vous en prie
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous me donnez l'occasion Monsieur le
Premier Ministre de rebondir parce que
on est vraiment dans cette commission
d'enquête dans l'idée de d'essayer de
avec toutes les auditions qu'on a eu
d'ailleurs mais de comprendre
quel est le l'organisation le soutien
potentiel et là vous nous expliquez et
je veux bien le croire d'ailleurs que
vous saviez
quand les renseignements vous donnez les
informations qui soutenaient
l'organisation et le regroupement des
Black Blocs enfin je résume en quelques
mots pouvez-vous nous dire qui
des groupes politiques nationaux que
vous avez que vous avez mentionné
globalement vous pouvez vous nous dire
ce que vous en saviez parce que
en fait c'est l'objet quand même de la
commission d'enquête notamment et puis
quand vous avez exprimé ça moi ça m'a
rappelé ce qu'on a ce qu'on a entendu à
Sainte-Soline
on sait je veux dire les forces de
l'ordre savait que qui allait avoir
effectivement une une telle une telle
déferlante et une telle organisation de
guerre comme nous a expliqué le général
en charge de tout l'Ouest de la France
de la zone militaire de gendarmerie
en disant cela tout à l'heure c'est que
nous avions des informations assez
précises sur les complicités qui
pouvaient exister entre les
organisations ext
qui faisait venir c'est black bloc et
d'ailleurs
s'il y avait un déploiement de force de
sécurité aussi important au moment des
manifestations dont on me disait à
l'époque il était surdimensionné et que
c'était parce qu'il était surdimensionné
et que rien ne justifie un tel
dimensionnement que les violences
avaient éclaté c'est précisément parce
que j'avais ces informations car nous
n'avions aucune raison de dimensionner
le dispositif de sécurité au-delà
des informations dont disposions par
plaisir de temps des manifestations en
sachant d'ailleurs que le
surdimensionnement des effectifs étaient
susceptibles de tendre les
manifestations et que les tensions dans
les manifestations ne serait imputables
c'était quand même un raisonnement très
curieux de penser que nous organisions
tout pour faire en sorte que notre prise
en cause soit plus manifeste c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe nous
organisions le dispositif de maintien de
l'ordre en fonction des informations
dont nous disposions et c'est parce que
nous avions des informations selon
lesquelles des Black Blocs en nombre
viendraient être à ces manifestations
que nous
configurions le dispositif de telle
sorte à pouvoir maîtriser ces individus
dangereux
le mot venu
non mais
c'était un peu votre question quand même
vous avez des informations etc quant aux
organisations qui ont de la mensualité à
l'égard de ce sont toutes les
organisations qui ne disent assez peu de
choses sur les exactions et beaucoup de
choses sur la police
comment vous n'avez pas compris pourtant
très perspicace
non non
ici parce que moi je suis libre de ma
parole et donc je crois que vous m'avez
parfaitement compris
quand on fait des manifestations sur le
permis de tuer quand on explique qu'un
ancien ministre de l'Intérieur est un
assassin quand on explique que les lois
qu'il a adopté sont des lois qui sont
destinées à autoriser la police à tirer
sur les manifestants ou sur les ou sur
ce qui sont en refus d'obtempérer et que
on n'a pas du tout la même intensité de
discours lorsqu'il s'agit de ce qui
casse parce qu'on est les théoriciens en
chef de La conceptionnalité de la
violence à la police on a un
positionnement politique
si ça vous paraît pas assez clair je
peux vous en dire davantage bah oui je
pense que c'est votre organisation qui
diffuse beaucoup ce type de discours et
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
je me pose à elle parce que ce discours
je ne l'accepte pas parce que ce
discours me paraît pas être un discours
responsable dans un contexte de tension
extrême et que je vous l'ai dit
publiquement suffisamment souvent je
trouve ces prospoyers à procédé qui
consiste à qualifier un journal de 20H
un ministre de l'Intérieur d'assassins
ensuite d'expliquer que ce ministre de
l'Intérieur est l'auteur d'un permis de
tuer alors que les faits sont ceux que
je viens de vous dire ça et lorsqu'il y
a des exactions dans les manifestations
de ne pas du tout réserver le même
qualification d'avoir la même attitude
où trouver Sadie vous moi je trouve ça
indigne
mais c'est pas je suis pas du tout
passionné pour le cas où ça vous aurez
échappé je suis simplement extrêmement
franc et direct je vous dis en face ce
que je pense de votre comportement voilà
parce qu'après monsieur ça fait des mois
que j'entends
pas eu l'occasion de me dire ce que j'en
pensais ben maintenant vous le savez
[Musique]
c'est que j'aimerais que lorsqu'il y a
des exactions dans les manifestations
plutôt que de théoriser la
consubstantialité de la violence à la
police vous ayez des propos aussi clairs
sur ceux qui créent les désordres dans
les manifestations et qui sont d'une
expressions
déraper ce débat
monsieur Mathieu
il faut il faut que chacun puisse
s'exprimer
rien n'interdit à quelqu'un qui ont été
tenus par le leader de votre formation
c'est pas une opinion sont des faits et
si vous voulez que je vous sorte la
déclaration de Monsieur Mélenchon et que
je vous fasse passer la vidéo je le fais
en direct vous serez pas très à l'aise
croyez-moi
j'ai pas du tout conclué encore des
questions il y a encore il y a encore
une question je pense qu'on va laisser
cette fois-ci Monsieur Le Fur s'est
exprimé donc Monsieur Le Fur je vous
passe la parole
merci
ce Président
j'ai le Premier ministre merci de votre
propos de sa clarté de ses nuances et
que on apprécie et que j'apprécie
vous avez beaucoup parlé des méthodes et
des moyens en cours de la manifestation
et également de ce qui précède
c'est-à-dire le renseignement j'aimerais
vous interroger sur un sujet que vous
avez peut-être un peu moins abordé qui
sont les mesures de police
administrative susceptibles d'être prise
avant la manifestation au moment où on
commence à disposer d'informations
nécessaires et qui permettent de se
préparer en quelque sorte trois volets
premier volet comment d'une manière ou
d'une autre obligée les manifestants je
parle des manifestants honnêtes ceux qui
ont le souci de promouvoir leurs idées
qui sont pas complices comment obliger
ces manifestants à s'organiser à
disposer d'un service d'ordre comme ça
pouvait exister va passer comment les y
aider peut-être et comment tolérer des
manifestants de bonne volonté qui ne se
donnerait pas les moyens de leur côté de
prévenir ce type d'exaction que nous
dénonçons tous première question et
peut-être avez-vous des exemples de
choses que vous avez pu faire ou de
choses que vous auriez souhaité faire et
qu'on ne peut plus faire deuxièmement
comment éviter que ces mouvements
violents
constituent des bases arrières
nous on a connu ça avec Notre Dame des
Landes qui a constitué une base arrière
considérable pour un certain nombre de
gens et quand ils regardent de plus près
vous mettez la pointe de compas à Notre
Dame des Landes vous
écartez l'autre bout du compas c'est les
Deux Sèvres c'est les difficultés
c'est Nantes qui a évolué de manière
inquiétante ces derniers temps mais ça
c'était après vos responsabilités et
troisième élément comment par des
mesures également administratives on
peut
diligenter des fouilles de véhicules des
fouilles d'individus tout ça préalable
la manifestation vous évoquez des gens
qui viennent avec des des boules de
pétanque ça doit pouvoir s'anticiper ce
contrôler d'une manière ou d'une autre
donc voilà voilà un peu les trois volets
de comment
on prévient en amont en amont à partir
du moment où dispose d'éléments
d'enseignement que vous disiez vous-même
que que dans les heures ou les jours qui
précèdent on les a ces renseignements
j'aurais dit que je pense que la
meilleure manière d'éviter que des
exigations de ce produit pendant les
manifestations dès lors que nous avons
l'identité de ceux qui sont susceptibles
de les commettre et de procéder
à des interpellations avant que la
manifestation de commence c'est ce que
nous avons fait
et qui nous a d'ailleurs été reprochés
en utilisant les moyens de police
administratives qui étaient d'autres
disposition à l'époque
interdiction de manifester etc et en
procédant à des interpellations à la
sortie des métros lorsque des individus
étaient armés de boules de pétanque etc
et qu'on était légitime à considérer que
bon et bien entendu il faut le faire
si on ne le fait pas on se trouve démuni
lorsque les
les manifestations commencent
mais il y a une contestation de cette
de ces mesures de police administrative
et une contestation par un certain
nombre d'acteurs qui considèrent que
empêcher les manifestants de manifester
alors que ils n'ont encore rien commis
pendant la mivet la manifestation est
une mesure préventive qui est de nature
à poser un problème au regard du
principe de liberté de manifester bon ce
n'est pas ma position ma position c'est
que si nous avons suffisamment
d'éléments
émanant des services de renseignement
pour être convaincus que il faut
utiliser les mesures de police
administrative à notre disposition pour
éviter que ces individus se joignent au
vortex et si l'interpellation est
possible en amont il faut le faire et si
nous ne le faisons pas alors nous
prenons le risque de voir ces
manifestations dégénérées
vous exerciez vos responsabilités on
avait le phénomène Notre-Dame-des-Landes
c'est à dire des gens qui se promenaient
sur des routes et qui étaient
interpellés arrêtés fouillé par ces
voyous qui qui occupaient les qu'est-ce
qu'on pouvait faire à l'époque pour
éviter ce genre de choses
ce qui était fait à l'époque c'est
d'organiser autant que faire ce pouvait
une présence policière sur les axes en
question pour éviter que
ce type de comportement de ce
généraliste et ce que nous avons fait
cette essayer d'agir en renseignement en
amont pour identifier le plus en amont
possible ces individus et regarder les
conditions dans lesquelles nous pouvions
les judiciariser lorsque les éléments
dont nous disposions enseignement
pouvaient permettre à l'action publique
de d'être enclenché je ne vois pas ce
que nous pouvons faire d'autres et plus
dans un État de droit
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Premier
Ministre non des membres de la
commission d'enquête je vous remercie de
cette audition extrêmement instructive
mes chers collègues nous avons convoqué
pour demain après-midi dans cette même
salle les collectifs des soulèvements de
la terre d'une part et de bassines non
merci d'autre part si les seconds
confirmé leur venue les premiers nous
ont signifié un refus donc nous en
tirons les conséquences donc rendez-vous
demain dans cette même salle à 16h
encore une fois merci beaucoup
l'ensemble d'entre vous et plus
particulièrement à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre je lève la séance